off the screen from Perry Davis find
pojevski oh rejected inside
Prosper the other way working on Santos
Braxton key has won it
Dallas survives in Cox Pavilion
[Applause]
gotta love it
up and down basketball attack the rim
might have been a foul no call
Prosper takes it all the way to the rim
through the contact
but right on key
what a finish fans on their feet in awe
of what they just saw
once again your final score here in Cox
Pavilion the Dallas Mavericks in
overtime win at
98-96 over the Golden State Warriors
here's that final bucket Prosper got all
the way inside and sure enough the
national champion from Virginia Braxton
key right place right time we've got
more summer league action coming your
way shortly on NBA TV in the ESPN app we
bring you Oklahoma City versus Indiana
straight ahead on NBA TV
foreign